Matt coronavirus is now a greater global
threat than terrorism says the World
Health Organization calling it the worst
enemy you can ever imagine
love curdling stuff which is why the
government is right to have passed
emergency laws this week to force people
into handcuffs if they refuse to go into
or stay in quarantine we need to wake up
to this threat because this virus has
killed more people than SARS with the
elderly and the vulnerable most at risk
it's already infiltrated schools doctors
surgeries and prisons here and globally
tens of thousands have been infected
with over 1,000 dead yet the government
and the Department of Health are still
playing a dam still allowing scores from
China to come here every day and
protecting the identities of carriers as
they unwittingly spread the disease this
despite professor Pio the microbiologist
who co-discovered a bolus in Britain is
likely to be hit by a major outbreak the
problem is we live in a country that in
recent years hadn't hasn't been hit by
any major viral threat we watch movies
are banded but we think it's sci-fi and
that it can't happen to us but it can
and it is essentially reference movies
because I think it was Dustin Hoffman an
outbreak where you see people and that's
what I'm afraid makes me really really
cautious of this but but again what you
do it the idea that we will authorize
police officers to put people in
handcuffs and effectively seal them in
Indians really really frightens me
but if you've got someone in the only
way you're going to contain it what so
one point where I am rather concerned
you're suggesting no one for more
flights in from China yeah the biggest
economic just as Britain merged into an
exciting new door the effective door and
once a bolt the door in the face over
the country that is worth a 17 20 25
percent of the global weeks which is
about March they think we other
countries have already closed the doors
the u.s. Australia New Zealand Saudi
they've already closed the doors because
you know this is the thing and I think
you know you mentioned handcuffing
people and I get why it looks trakone
Ian but you know it is true these people
look these people are walking when
of mass destruction Lord yes they are
you know the thing is and I keep on
hearing stories about Oh flu every year
cuz thousands of people yes it does have
killers they're elderly but actually
this virus is gonna kill more than their
Lee it's gonna kill people that have
underlying health conditions and that's
many many thousands of people when you
say just does it when you have this
professor Pio the guy who knows about
this stuff saying Britain is likely to
take a major hit we should listen to it
yeah I just wanna find interesting about
about this subject is that you know last
week on this show you had a doctor on
who was saying we should all be aware
take precautions keep informed but not
be sensationalist about it well and here
we are this week with you going this is
my doctor is wrong cow this government
have been too passive and they've been
proved I too agree with that at all in
fact I am impressed by the way global
and health agencies have handled this
they've they've kept public aware it's a
very difficult thing to calibrate public
awareness versus panic is a really
difficult thing to calibrate and the
thing about it is that everybody who has
all the cases have been identified
everybody who has it all the people that
they are likely to have may potentially
passed it on to have been identified
which means that it is very yes we
should it's not it's not a simple thing
and we should be aware but the efforts
to contain it are significant and
serious I'll just bring in the
director-general of the World Health
Organization you mentioned a terrorism
analogy he does this is dr. Ted Ross of
ever yeeeeesss peeking on Tuesday a
virus can have more powerful
consequences than any terrorist action
and that's true and if the world doesn't
want to wake up and consider this enemy
virus as public enemy number one I don't
think we will learn from our lessons now
can I just suggest perhaps how we could
learn from this wearing living in an
increasingly globalized world where were
you're right we are dependent on the
Chinese economy 15 to 20 percent
whatever it is and so I think
considering he's just himself said isn't
it dangerous than terrorism what perhaps
we could do going forward because
whether it's sauce or murse or now the
corona virus
they are invariably linked to hygiene
standards and cross-contamination from
certain wild species of animal we need
to clamp down on that happening at root
and that may mean depending a dependent
regardless of which country is that may
mean some form of collective action to
enforce standards and penalties if those
standards are announced it's in China
well China's already doing that actually
they've just started to do that they've
shut down yeah because I think even they
realized this is going to get out of
hand yeah so because keep in mind
coronavirus is a third reincarnation of
this particular virus sauce and MERS are
also coronavirus it's the same strains
of after the government's advices
they're telling people if you've been
somewhere that would think of you think
you might from self isolate now what in
God's name does self isolate mean it's a
really cavalier attitude if you have a
family and you come back to your house
in in an extrusive lots of houses new
your semi-detached you had whatever and
and and you go home you have a seat you
have a partner you have kids how the
hell do self isolate in a house that
maybe has no Detention Center this
should be an attention center yes you
would
you get coronavirus and you put in a
detentions this thing about
self-isolation I do think that we could
have more public information about do
the parents laws were passed was cause a
bloke in the world tried to walk out of
a quarantine Center where he was
stationed means I mean the government's
already said we've had lots of advice as
to what you need to do to prevent the
spread of this disease and that comes
down to personal hygiene washing your
hands this and disinfect and covering
your mouth what's covering them up on
you when you see when you sneeze so I
mean me personally I recently went
through it spent seven hours in Istanbul
Airport which is a massive international
and so an about three days later I was
bed bound shivering for about seven days
straight
coughing recently I went to the doctors
I went to the doctors said twice is to
make just to make sure and he gave me
the art gave me the all-clear so I have
this but but but I isolated myself in my
rooms with
seven-day period didn't see anybody my
flatmate I did I didn't really go into
close contact with them at all so cell
isolation is a thing that you can do
even if it has to be advice what is it
no one's bento no ones we give because
it means different things that
difference if we if if countries in the
world flout human rights standards if
they flower even economic policy the IMF
comes down heavy on them this particular
thing with viruses we need an
international body maybe the World
Health Organization that enforces
standards on hygiene and then penalties
for not sticking to that because by the
way Merce which is the Middle Eastern
version of SAS I mean it's passed from
camel to human beings and I've seen
videos of better wins drinking camel
urine thinking it's some form of
medicine for them you know there needs
to be standard set now of course then
you can't do much about their lone
person doing that but the live markets
you referred to Y can be clamped down
why weren't even Steve Walsh as a name a
week ago he's the so-called super
because not to name and shame of course
not but there will be people who have
been close to him who have been near him
who will need to know so they can report
to a center they can be tested well
because it creates stigma and panic when
scapegoating and the thing about it is
that listen this particular individual
did everything that he was supposed to
do everybody who was potentially at risk
was tracked and identified and I feel
like if you name people then you not
only then that you start stigmatizing
people but you create a sense of panic
when the reality is that in his case it
was actually managed and continuing and
you've effectively call them a weapon of
mass destruction
yes I can't suggest both things either
your plan is that we is that we forcibly
isolate people or we all we all we name
and chain them doing both doesn't
forcibly isolate them if they won't go
into quality we don't just grab a bunch
of wines one that's why they have to
pass a law Rachel one cares the Lexus of
one case they pass this you only in law
you see you're like the person this guy
is talking about on the screen here
you're not getting it you're not getting
the potential you're not going
absolutely
we've just had a different reaction to
you I absolutely share your sense of
concern I just have a different reaction
Etan so let's begin about the secure
liberties and the human rights of a guy
when when the rest of the planet is at
risk we can't he it's not about naming
and shaming it's that contacting the
people who he was close to that's all